Today you are in for a treat, because
we are going to perform brain to audio,
yes listen to music straight from
your brain, kind of, and more. Yes,
I hear you asking, Doctor,
how is this even possible?
Well, this new paper showcases an EEG-based
technique to perform this science-fiction like
experiment. Normally, EEG, electroencephalography
means that we place electrodes on the scalp,
and then, we listen to the brain from the
outside. And by that, I mean looking at
the electric activity. However, here, this work
uses Intracranial EEG, that requires electrodes
to be on the surface of the brain. Thus making
it an invasive technique that makes scientists
able to listen to the brain straight from
its surface. So what can we do with that?
And the answer is: absolutely miraculous things.
Let’s look at the experiment design and see what
happened. First, a song is played to 29 patients,
this was Another Brick in the Wall the classic
from Pink Floyd, then an auditory spectrogram is
created from this song. This enables us to look
at the song and understand a little better where
we are and what is happening. Then, scientists
recorded the neural activity of the brain at
the points where the electrodes were placed, and
created a spectrogram from information that was
obtained from the brain. This is a decoding step,
and the one in this particular diagram was done by
a neural network. Decoding real neural information
by using a digital neural network. What a time to
be alive! Now, hold on to your papers, because we
are going to look at the two spectrograms, and…oh
my goodness. The information that was read from
the brain indeed refers to the same song. No
question about it. Due to copyright constraints,
I can’t play it here, but you can listen to
it through the link in the video description,
and I have to say that of course, this is not
HiFi quality, but if you know the song, you can
tell what is being played in the brain, and even
sing the lyrics to it. Absolutely incredible.
The paper also showcases a ton of
little golden nuggets of information,
I loved this chart that tells us exactly how
the quality of the reconstruction increases with
the number of electrodes, little measurement
points being used on the brain. Adding more
of typically typically increases the
resolution of the information we get,
but also increases the noise as well. So here,
a proper way of decoding helps a great deal.
This paper is an interesting showcase of what
is possible through the power of research,
and since this data has to be read from the
surface of your brain, I would not worry
about anyone eavesdropping on which scholarly
paper you are thinking about. For instance,
a couple hundred episodes ago, we talked
about an absolutely amazing paper that allowed
brain-to-text transcription. It took patients
who had a paralyzed hand and all the test subject
has to do is imagine writing the letters, and
they magically appear on the screen. And now,
hold on to your papers Fellow Scholars, and just
look at how quickly it goes! 90 characters per
minute with over 94% of accuracy, which can
be improved to over 99% of accuracy with an
additional autocorrect technique. That is
absolutely amazing. We can learn a ton from
these papers. For instance, in that one, we
learned that it is quite remarkable that even
years after paralysis, the motor cortex is still
strong enough to be read by a brain-computer
interface well enough for such typing speed and
accuracy. It truly feels like we are living in a
science fiction world. Imagine how many people
around the world we could help with this!
So today, brain to text to possible, and brain
to audio is also possible. But here comes the
best part - for people who are unable
to communicate with us through speech,
they can not only write to us, but with this,
we can even reconstruct the musicality of their
speech as well straight from the brain.
Imagine if we could have heard the late
Stephen Hawking talk like that. How
amazing would that have been? Wow.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!